hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Orcs Must Die - I'm here with
Tom Yeo yep that's him so I just wanted
to take a second to let you guys who
haven't played Orcs Must Die know how
the skull system works you get skulls
for completing levels with proficiency
like you'll get 5 out of 5 if you did it
perfectly didn't let a single one
through got certain number of points or
whatever and you can spend your skulls
on your gear and your gear is what you
get
like traps and weapons that you get
there's all sorts of traps and weapons
going on that cleanses okay some of it
you get through the story like the
barricade in the archer Guardian a shock
zapper and all this sort of stuff other
stuff you have to buy separately I think
that's how it was with my my crossbow
which I'm actually gonna use next time
yo can also get whoa a dwarven hammer
that's new wind belt was always good I
think I will pick up that one I always
like the wind bill alright anyway so I
got that we're ready to go right Tom yep
ready okay here we go no chasm don't
fail oh and apparently we missed one
work that was riding a cart to the end
oh yeah well that's cheap yeah so ah I
don't know what it was with that what's
your deal anyway okay I descend Oh who's
worked through the rip the order mages
were we
and old unwilling to rule as they should
the orcs were a tool to carve away the
corruption film no major power trip huh
I got it right okay that time I could
actually hear the dialogue yeah me too
kind of nice um what are you doing I
don't know what you doing out there okay
I gotta get these one too okay now we're
ready radio where they kept from ready
over here uh yeah okay
oh all right here comes the epic
headshotting skill miss miss miss miss
miss miss miss miss there we go I'm
getting into it come on
okay I'm I'm much worse than I said I
was my skills are all rusty
hahaha okay behind us behind us Oh on
this end hmm I didn't see this one
their way to zoom in on the cookie on
middle-mouse oh is it yeah I like the
crossbow because it's much faster
headshots are still an instant kill it's
just basically better than the platypus
unless the blender books upgrades
differently I would say yeah I think
it's better that's why I cost more you
get the gun first for free so I suppose
front of back front of Ecch
uh both maybe probably I got this one
alright fine well I'm not shooting from
a distance a wicked headshot so great hi
I fell I can't I can't I can't move my
mouse anymore like I cannot move my
mouse like I [ __ ] up I [ __ ] up
I'll shoot him if they come across my
line of sight there we go Oh winning
winning oh I'm so great even though I'm
crippled and and all my my controls are
backwards like DUP like S is for W is
backwards so I'm playing double extra
crippled right now
that's so weird yeah I wish you can see
this right now because of ridiculous God
all right here here we go again
maybe throw yourself off the cliff again
that's probably good idea there we go
OOP okay
oh good there goes oh there we go here
we go I don't care about the score yeah
but we only have 14 left shut up yes you
care about your skull so much
okay I can't hit for [ __ ] anymore oh
yeah I forgot because it's not directly
where it is that it's that you can aim
like a little bit up I forgot about that
cool this used to be a Norton
what's with the skull buffs on the
ground is that like an extra skull yeah
that's just a bonus to go really yep
like that you can spend on stuff yeah
how bad but just to ever get that first
okay
yeah it's weird with the headshot to get
a name like slightly above them you
doing okay over there
yep got a handle I don't look so good
I'll help you out headshots yeah
what the what are you doing planning
with something ID distracted me mm-hmm
something for your face final wave
already please
up my side I should project a picture to
that oh I'll send the card over here you
can do that yeah just a switch all right
it goes oh that hit none thank you so
much for that
glad to help
and another miss
just mirror those little ones faster
than they used to be had they seemed
about the same to me
okay I'm gay we're always getting
annoying I'm getting come Oh what are
you doing some over here what shut up
did you forget him okay ah then again I
had a lot of runes that I didn't spend
so that was my bad also I didn't use my
push thing I totally forgot about that
probably important I'm an idiot
see the way
I remember having it's been a while
since I played Orcs Must Die so I
remember having this sort of like
combination with the lightning thing
yeah yeah all the times
together we will sweep generally what I
use get merry about alarm you were made
babies I would sooner rip your beating
heart from your chest okay No
let's see I can't place it in here it'll
hurt a lot
six there I got you covered
boy I am out bring it on
I think they fixed something by doing it
this way because I used to be able to
push them when they spawned I used to be
able to push them right off the edge
inside their spawn uh-huh and I kind of
chain push them so that whoa that guy's
big is a guy no hunter
even Hedgehog Wow yeah they're tough
mine
hi I killed them what the there up above
what da hell I don't think you're up
here I don't know I didn't see the other
there's no other rift up there
oh you serious police traps are useless
I can't hit [ __ ]
okay now that other rift is opening oh
oh wow I see wait is it up here yeah
it's up here sometimes I almost feel bad
for the orcs except not really
man I used to be good at English shuts
Oh these things just don't die instantly
that's not fair
oh it's another one help me could help
me
my dad would die yeah I died thank you
so much for all your help
I died yeah what are you doing I told
you I was gonna die I tried to help you
you didn't try very hard you should have
been better
you should have charged in there you
know to help me I hit him with lightning
maybe these all hey hey do you think you
spring traps hurts
launching them up there maybe it should
had it going - yeah
I want the lightning spell oh can I get
that I bought it this is cuz you've been
playing in the off time no I I'm on with
this character oh okay
I didn't get any extra stalls all right
whatever
see I swear I'm the worst ever I used to
be good at headshots or else they used
to be easier to get headshots the hitbox
was bigger or whatever but now whoa yeah
see you're launching the guys over here
sorry one two five okay we're not gonna
get five skulls again because you
weren't a team player hey you're the one
that died you're the what that let me
die oh so see they're being knocked down
here we gotta get rid of these yeah I'm
gonna get rid of them where is it oh
that's up there somewhere
oh wait is there nothing up there all
done the Train the Train is knocking him
down sell those I will I can only sell
one have them pointing the other way I
screw you I'm just spiked rattling all
right spike traps aren't very effective
shut up spike traps gossiped traps wish
I had acid traps
lots of acid traps oh boy I'll crap you
in trouble rock bones I don't see how
you deal on your own
no problem
oh crap ah see what happens baby see my
coin like slows you down yeah - rah
Colin's down here it's um in your face
in your face spike traps get better once
you upgrade them to the slowy version I
guess they're still pretty crappy though
shut your face there's only 300 there's
a reason for that
so you can spam a lot of them I'm in
trouble
save Jeff oh I use my bouche I boost him
see I win oh yeah I'm the best yeah
where's my surface bridge the surface
area damage ratios are very good yep
shut up more spiked rounds all right
fine more spike traps look they're
coming up see I used to be ogres used to
take extra damage there we go and
headsets are really working hard now I
claim you're missing some
now we're fine up here yeah whatever
there we go
used to be I swear everyone watching
this is like but I I did I was good at
headshots sure I used to know you okay
up there oh yeah
easy-peasy let's take a moment to
reflect on my mistakes
oh my kidding I didn't make any mark
black guys
I guess I should let them at least get
room ice by crabs ports or killing
maybe killstreak might as well kill him
early though shut up I play how I want
to play play how you play fine I will
my place is better way
yeah Aqil but I'm okay
Yesi what are you doing got your own to
worry about
hey these guys are taken care of
they don't look taken care of oh crap it
looks like they're cramping your stuff
I got one of those final round final
round you're actually with enough traps
you don't have to do anything besides
just hit him with the wind
they're up above now they're not they're
down below
yep
what I besides the rock alone I haven't
seen anything new right not so far
everything's been the same as it has
been in Orcs Must Die 1 and then the
arcs look a little different though I
guess I guess we'll see a lot more in
depth to the game later I'm sure they're
okay it's supposed to be quite a few new
enemies I hope so I don't want to call
this a lazy sequel right although the
music is the same yeah news as awesome
as it is yeah somehow I feel like this
should have been more of an expansion
guys gonna see but you know it's an
indie game yeah yeah guys as good as
this what how do we like oh yeah I died
that's right cuz you let me die was my
fault I'm pretty sure it was I'm pretty
sure all right
that's oh that's new what is that dwarf
Guardian yeah closer bonds I like that
anyway that's all the time we got for
this episode thank you guys so much for
watching and as always we'll see you in
the next video bye bye bye